[Music]
foreign
so here in this video we will dive deep
into the ancient seas and time travel
back to the past to unravel the
evolution of the Megalodon shark we will
begin with the earliest sharp ancestors
and go through the evolutionary pathway
that leads to the Monstrous Meg
therefore we will also get to see its
ancestors its ancient cousins and where
it came from also we will prop into
whether there are surviving descendants
or not so let's get to it
it all began with a small ancient fish
called the akantodian which lived during
the silurian to the Permian periods
approximately 450 to 250 million years
ago despite their name they were not
true shocks but rather a group of
primitive jot fishes that are considered
to be the beginning of shock evolution
so around 380 million years ago during
the middle of the devonian period a new
genus got the Antarctica emerge around
the same time a species known as the
gladosilic also developed this marks the
earliest appearance of a group that
would be recognizable as modern day
sharks however it's possible that they
were initially associated with the
Chimera lineage and thus not precisely
classified as sharks then the
Carboniferous period starting 359
million years ago referred to as the
Golden Age of Charles due to an
Extinction event in the devonian period
that wiped out many fish species this
allowed sharks to thrive resulting in a
diverse range of shapes and species
during this era some unusual ancient
shocks evolved from the Chimera family
these include the stethacantas with a
unique animal shaped back fin and the
helicoprion featuring a spiral bust saw
like lower jaw
around 252 million years ago the Permian
mass extinction event eliminated about
96 percent of marine species including a
diverse range of sharp species but some
survived and in the early Jurassic
Period about 195 million years ago the
hexagoniforms or six Gill sharks an
ancient group of modern sharks emerged
during this phase they developed
flexible Jaws that could extend enabling
them to consume larger prey and they
could also swim at higher speeds
around 107 million years ago the kratoxy
Reiner an ancient shop measuring up to 8
meters or 26 feet in length and weighing
around 4.5 tons became one of the
largest shelves of its time having a
similar appearance and built to a modern
great white shark it was an apex
predator and played on a large variety
of marine animals including smaller
mosasaurs although there is no direct
link between it and Meg it does
represent an early specimen of the
mackerel shot group the one that the
mech also belongs to
a little bit later a hundred million
years ago nikino lamina and the creta
lamina came into being these two species
of shops represent one of the earliest
members of the group called orthodont
day which is the family of sharks the
orders and the later megalodons would
belong to and therefore either one of
them would have been the great Granddad
or great great great great great
grandpappy of the giant shark we would
see in a synozoic era these two existed
around 100 million years ago in the
early Cretaceous Period
so after the KT Extinction event a large
number of marine reptiles disappeared
sharks like the pale yogurt haradon
became prominent in the oceans
researchers are particularly intrigued
by its relationship to the great white
shark and a Megalodon the tooth
serrations of the Megalodons and great
whites closely resembled to those of the
Paleo caridon this similarity has led
some experts to propose the paleocare
Cardon as a potential ancestor to these
two shark species
so around 55 to 45 million years ago the
orders obliquis previously known as the
lamb obliqua was one of the earliest
macro shocks to have evolved and was a
huge Beast measuring about 9 meters or
30 feet long so it is here that the
largest predatory shark that ever lived
the Megalodon can be traced back to
directly the mech is thought to be one
of the odorless obliquis direct
descendants but there were quite a few
other species that evolved between the
time frame of the obliquis and the Meg
so let's get to them
after this obliquis the next in line
according to the fossil records is the
Auditors auriculators which evolve
around 35 million years ago this is
another one of the sharks of the genus
odorless and also closely related to the
later species Megalodon the largest
individuals of this group of the species
were about 9.5 meters or 31 feet long
given that evolution is a slow process
it involves inheritable and beneficial
point mutations over long periods of
time the different species of especially
sharks are hard to identify a place in
accordance but this is the best we can
do
from that we come to the orderus
sokolovi this extinct shark species
measuring about 6 meters or 20 feet
belongs to the odonto Day family which
is the evolutionary lineage of the
Megalodon it might represent a
transitional stage between the oradas
Oracle ladders and the next in line the
orders on gustadance it is on occasion
classified in the caraclus genus
alongside the rest of the orders and
this is still up to debate because of
its resemblance to other species it's
challenging to precisely determine the
emergence and the extinction periods of
this species but it is commonly
classified as a transitional stage like
a missing link between the oracleaders
and the angostudence
yeah now we come to the anger students
this shark species evolved around the
same time or as a quick evolutionary
Branch from the auriculates and the
sokolovi with some researchers saying
that the sokolovi was actually the
direct ancestor and that the ungustedins
was the next step in evolution and
speciation it lived around the article
scene and the myosin epochs around 33 to
22 million years ago and grew to be
around 11 to 12 meters or 36 to 39 feet
in length now after that we come to the
odoras jupitances now the last in line
of the probable ancestors or maybe just
a cousin of the Megalodon this shot is
13.5 meters or 44 feet long jupitances
is of the same genus of otorus see the
difference between this shark and the
Megalodon is like the difference between
a lion and a tiger they are both in the
same genus and would have existed around
the same time however the jupitances did
evolve from maybe the psychology and the
remnants of the ancient auricularis or
new and gustadance or maybe an unknown
transitional species but this is the
loss before the Megalodon comes into
being
so those are the ancestors and probably
the cousins that evolve parallel to the
Megalodon so finally after 430 million
years of sharp Evolution we come to the
biggest shark that ever lived the
Megalodon the odidos Megalodon it can
grow up to 18 meters or 60 feet and
weigh up to 60 tons it dominated the
Seas for 20 million years until it
suddenly died off 3.6 million years ago
during this long period of time it would
have competed with its fellow Autodesk
shark species outliving all of them it
would have also come into contact with
Olivia tan melvale the early sperm
whales and the early killer whales which
would have been the cause of his
Extinction
sadly there are no more ordered species
of sharks after the Megalodon and it was
the loss of its lineage and hence no
descendants of this giant shark
and also sad to say that the great white
sharks although formidable and
terrifying in looks are not related to
the Megalodon they evolved in a parallel
line and they have their own ancestors
and ancestral tree
so we have come to the end of the video
I hope you have enjoyed watching this
one do hit the like button for support
and subscribe but most of all smash that
Bell icon for regular updates on new
videos here on this channel till the
next one take care fam